[Music]
all right this
will be exciting the formula e racer
against magnus 10 and whenever you're
ready maximilian just to make your move
okay he starts by pushing a pawn in the
corner he doesn't go for an opening that
we call the grand prix attack
uh this is very different strategy for
maximilian but he's playing quick that's
the main thing
um off to a quick start for the formula
eraser here
that's an interesting strategy perhaps
to surprise
magnus h10 and uh he has advanced his
other rook pawn um gaining space on
those
flanks yeah this is a little bit
different than what we've seen before
yeah i can safely say magnus carlsen has
never faced this opening before
okay small pause there for max he does
lose a pawn unfortunately but
the game's still on he's about to attack
magnus's knight
okay oh he has walked into a check
though that could
be deadly how's he gonna react he's got
the right instincts he's moving quickly
but
um he needs to up that pace even more uh
to stay in this game now
it's all about gaining as many moves as
possible yes
there is a problem though because
maximilian's king has taken
a walk into the center and is now under
check which means he has to move he has
to move it forward
and when the king moves forward it
becomes a haunted b
creature yeah and you can tell
maximilian he has good instincts he's
already highlighting the squares the
moves he wants to play
but he is pausing just before he
completes those moves so um
okay he needs to up that pace he needs
to just get those moves on the board get
that king to safety
um magnus has been greedy taking pieces
but that doesn't matter it's all about
time right now
maximilian down to only 30 seconds
um how many moves can he get out on the
board he should speed up a little bit if
he wants to gain some more moves
big problem now the white king and white
queen they are both attacked
queen disappears and now is just about
securing as
many moves as possible just keep those
moves coming
play fast the adrenaline is pumping yeah
maximilian is doing everything right
13 seconds though and ticking down okay
he's playing faster now
he just needs to keep just stop worrying
about the pieces now it's all about the
speed
keep your pieces defended push forward
there we go finds a good move
um develop that bishop maximilian push
your king
oh there we go time runs out time runs
out and if you press continue we'll see
how many moves you lasted 14 moves 14
moves how do you feel about that
maximilian
mixed emotions i'm not
good strategy thoughts from my side um
no but yeah it's all right it's already
it's kind of i mean i did better
already um but yeah some some moves
we have the standings here so we have
rain william wilson on top with
uh 30 moves cooper getting junior 16.
and right behind cuba gojin jr we find
you maximilian with four
team moves and we know magnus 10 years
old he was
quite fierce so what was it like
facing the 10 year old magnus carlsen
it was cool and i have to say like
especially it's like always in
in our sport as well um you know the one
thing is to practice but then the other
thing is to
to do the competition live and there is
definitely some more
pressure uh and no it's it was cool
it's it's a ride and i mean really hands
off from
from from these guys as well it's for me
always very fascinating to see
people from from other sports from other
businesses to
to be on this extremely high level and
yeah i know where i was
when i was uh 10 years old in parting
and
yeah to see yeah magnus carlsen
being so unbelievably strong already in
this
in his young age it's yeah it's very
impressive